c'est un accessoire désormais
indispensable si vous empruntez les
transports en commun à saint quentin en
yvelines
le masque est obligatoire avant de
monter dans un bus ou dans un train sous
peine d'amendés aux heures de pointe
c'est à dire entre 6h30 et 9 heures 30
et de 16 heures à 19 heures il faut par
ailleurs être muni d'une attestation de
votre employeur enfin si vous souhaitez
privilégier une mobilité plus douce la
vélostation situé à la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines a rouvert ses portes
sur rendez vous il est possible de louer
un vélo ou encore de le faire réparer
les boutiques de l'espace saint quentin
rouvrent peu à peu depuis quelques jours
en mettant en place des mesures
sanitaires spécifiques les bars cafés et
restaurants restent quant à eux fermés à
l'exception de ceux qui proposent de la
vente à emporter
de leur côté les agriculteurs saint
quentinois maintiennent les dispositifs
mis en place pendant la crise enfin un
groupe facebook permet aux commerçants
et producteurs de mettre en avant leurs
actions
les sept déchetteries de saint quentin
en yvelines sont ouvertes partiellement
certains services comme la mise à
disposition de sacs déchets verts ou la
collecte des bandes textiles sont encore
suspendus
la collecte des encombrants a repris l
le 11 mai dernier
notez que leur accès se fait uniquement
sur rendez vous le déconfinement a
permis la reprise de balades en forêt en
revanche les parcs et les jardins de
saint quentin en yvelines reste fermé la
pratique des activités sportives est
également de nouveau autorisée avec tout
de même plusieurs critères en extérieur
et en respectant certaines distances 10
mètres minimum pour les activités de
vélo et du jogging 4 mètres carrés pour
le yoga ou encore le fitness les golf de
saint quentin en yvelines ont également
rouvert avec des mesures d'hygiène et de
sécurité
en revanche pour se divertir
culturellement il faudra faire preuve
encore de patience cinéma salle de
spectacles musées reste fermé pour les
médiathèques tout de même vous pouvez
accéder gratuitement aux ressources en
ligne jusqu'au 30 juin